hi it's been a while up until I released
the flying fantasy beasts video there'll
be a card on the screen summer and link
in the description this channel saw
something of a hiatus for a couple of
months as the title of the video
wherever it is suggests my thesis had a
lot to do with that there were other
factors I should point out as you'll see
in a vlog very shortly I went on holiday
for two weeks with some friends from
school we went to France so we could all
properly unplug from work was the first
time I've had a proper break since three
years ago and then for a week before
that I was volunteering with my old
Scout troop which was this amazing week
where I was a leader on a camp where
previously had been a scout and we were
teaching the kids how to make fires cook
on fires guts and prepare and cook
rabbits
we built a zipline on the campsite which
we did when we were kids and we went
coasteering
and generally we just gave the kids the
childhood that we had we the leaders had
when we were in that Scout troop which
was so fulfilling I actually wrote a
blog post about the experience because I
went without my phone or without
internet for a week which is the first
time item plug from social media
probably for like ten years so there's a
link to that in the description I have a
blog by the way however the main point
of this video is talking about thesis
stuff and specifically why I had to
submit my thesis again so the way that
you get a PhD is pretty simple
really you do original research for
however many years you write it up into
a thesis over several months or a year
and then you submit that thesis your
examined on it in a visor and then
you're either awarded a PhD or not
simple I mean obviously it's not and
there are also other steps which people
tend to gloss over in how a PhD is
awarded and specifically the steps after
you do your volva if you've watched this
channel for a while you might remember
that I did my advisor in February and I
did a video about the experience which
was both terrifying and enjoyable and
kind of a weird mix of emotions but I
passed the fiver I was awarded the PhD
subject to Corrections because the PhD
thesis that you submit for examination
in the Bible is the first version of
your PhD the way that the fiber works is
they basically say
yes but or no the but is the corrections
aspect to it there are two kinds of
Corrections at least in the UK system
those are major Corrections and minor
Corrections now minor Corrections is
often stuff basically just spelling
grammar all the way up to we want you to
restructure how the thesis is but we
don't want you to do any additional work
anything up to doing additional work is
basically classed as minor and that's
the kind of thing where you get a few
months to make those changes and then
you send it off to your internal
examiner they verify that you've done
the changes asked for and then boom
you're away you can graduate the second
kind of Corrections the major
Corrections are the ones that I've got
now the word major implies that
something was fundamentally wrong and
that's not actually the case I thought
that up until my fiverr what the
examiners stressed in my viber was they
were giving me major Corrections but
that was only because they wanted me to
do some additional work that was sort of
the necessary condition for major the
actual stuff that needed to go to the
PhD was only in the end a couple of
pages extra and I barely had to touch
the majority of it apart from a few
spelling mistakes here and there and a
few bits of cuts and a few equations to
tweak almost everything that I had to do
was actually very little space on the
page in the end the key point though is
that if you get given major Corrections
you have to do additional work on your
thesis and then resubmit it everybody
who gets Corrections has to resubmit
their thesis but if you get major
Corrections then there's usually a bit
more work involved than you have to do
extra stuff the original work plus the
extra stuff then forms the second form
of your PhD thesis which fingers crossed
gets accepted by your examiners and then
that's the final version so everybody
who does a PhD actually has a few steps
added on to the end of the process you
do your original work you write it up
you go through a fiver and then you have
to make changes to that thesis and then
you resubmit it so what I've been doing
for the past couple of months is that
extra work which turned out whilst it
wasn't a huge amount extra to do there
were so many problems to overcome in
actually doing it I want this to be a
relatively short video explaining where
I've been so when it go into the full
details but basically I had to do an
extra section of one of my chapters
which effectively verified what I'd done
in the rest of the thesis
since something I really should have
thought of before I submitted and I felt
kind of dumb in retrospect for not doing
it in the first place the problem was in
order to do that sort of verification
I needed to get another data set and it
was a data set that wasn't available
from the source that originally used
which was the ECMWF I had to find it
somewhere else
and what I did to begin with was do all
the extra work given a nearly identical
data set to what I needed because it was
the one I had access to from the ECMWF
however I under odd about it and I
wasn't happy I wasn't happy with doing
it with an approximated version I wanted
to get the actual completely accurate it
was basically trying to find a string
function rather than geopotential which
was depending on how you look at the
world isn't there's no difference but
there is a difference so I did all the
corrections work I then have a crisis of
confidence and then I went on this epic
adventure to try and find the data set
that I needed and that took quite a
while not the several months that I was
missing for though because eventually I
did find the data but it wasn't in the
nicest form previously when I'd used
geophysical data I was able to download
one file which had all the data that I
wanted from for example 1979 to 2012 and
it was a low resolution which is what
you use for the whole thesis it was
every six hours boom one giant file of
like 20 gigabytes however because this
new dataset came from a different
provider which was cedar actually based
in the same city I believe as the ECMWF
but different for bureaucracy reasons
data from this source wasn't available
in that one file form and that meant
that I had to download I think it was
about 250 different data files that
covered it for I think it was a month at
a time and then you had one month
another month another month motherland'
I couldn't back download them I
literally had to sit for a whole day was
like 18 hours clicking to download them
one after the other because my browser
would only accept so many and I couldn't
be bothered to write a program that was
just going to automatically download
them because you had to request it and
then download it and then wait for the
download and then anyway there were
problems and then when I had the data
there were still problems because it
turned out there were a few gaps in the
data
tonight it was on a different grid I
then had to be sample it in the vertical
and then eventually after about a month
I think it was of fiddling around with
this thing I eventually was able to redo
the work by down in the first place
and what did I find almost exactly the
same result which was a little bit
depressing but I knew that it was
exactly correct it wasn't their
approximation there wasn't any doubt I
knew that I had done exactly the right
thing and that was the most gratifying
thing about the process of doing the
corrections and resubmitting the thesis
it was that I knew what I was doing when
I did the thesis the first time around
it kind of I'm sure a lot of PhD
students would agree with me in this in
writing a thesis it feels kind of like a
series of stumbles one after the other
and eventually they just kind of acts
almost accidentally form a body of work
it's very rare that you'll come across
someone whose thesis was well defined
from the beginning to the end and it was
just a series of filling in the gaps
almost everybody's I swear is kind of
made up on the fly and adapted to
results that you find and new ideas that
you have and you know you might find
something that blows a whole section out
of the water and you have to replace it
and it ends up being this kind of
garbled Frankenstein's monster for
creation with the correction though I
had a really clear idea what I needed to
do I had a plan I followed it through
boom got the results interpreted them
wrote them up and I realized how much
the PhD had changed me because for the
first time in my academic career and by
that I mean my master's on my PhD I
wasn't feeling the need to verify what
I'd done with my supervisor I did send
the results to my supervisor and just
made sure that the corrections sort of
the interpretation of the results was
what they expect which was what he said
but I felt like I was in command I felt
like I was actually doing science on my
own I had the thought processes down I
knew the statistical tricks I knew how
to get the data do the analysis how to
write it up and I kind of sat back
afterwards and I was like yeah I'm I'm a
scientist now it may be a bit late in
the day but it was an amazing feeling to
be like yeah this PhD has really changed
the way I think I felt very lucky
actually I felt very grateful to have
gone through the experience and to be
given this way of viewing the
and the tools and sort of tricks that
I've learned so basically that's where
I've been for the past a couple of
months mostly working on thesis stuff
completing Corrections resubmitting as a
standard practice for almost all PhDs
and then a few other sort of more fun
bits afterwards I just wanted to make
this quick video to update you on what
I've been doing and to shed a light on
those hidden steps at the end of the PhD
which no one seems to talk about but
yeah that's what I wanted to talk about
I'm really excited to be back making
videos doing the flying beast video was
a real labor of love it was a very long
progress I was checking for my emails I
actually started the progress with that
in January so very happy that that one's
out there loads more science videos that
are just waiting to be edited there are
some exciting collaborations coming up
and yeah I'm very very happy to be back
also a massive shout outs the people who
support me on patreon and ball with me
whilst I was await necessarily doing
other things thank you so much your
support does mean the world incidentally
if he found the fine beasts video
interesting I actually did a commentary
track so like a director's commentary on
how I made the video and sort of talking
about how he approached it the
philosophy of how I do science videos
there'll be a link in the description if
you're a patreon you can get it
automatically if you can't get it then
you can become a patreon which would
directly support what I do anyway that's
enough thank you very much for watching
you'll see me very soon and I'll see you
in the next one
you